يوجد أكثر من 900 برج في دبي ،
وقد تم بناء كل واحد منهم
في الأربعين عامًا الماضية قبل أن
بدت دبي هكذا في عام 1979 ، وكان هذا المبنى 39
طابقًا في وسط
الصحراء العربية ، وهذا هو مركز دبي
التجاري العالمي.  أطول مبنى
بين مومباي وأثينا بما في
ذلك العالم العربي كله ، مما أحدث
تأثيرًا وهو دليل جيلمور ،
المدير العام الأول لموظف المراكز
التجارية ومدير المركز التجاري الذي يقف
بمفرده في الصحراء ، كان الناس في
حيرة شديدة من سبب قيام مبنى شاهق
يتم وضعها في أرض مفتوحة ،
أعتقد أنها ربما تكون الأولى من نوعها في العالم
حتى أنها حصلت على زيارة من الملكة إليزابيث في
يوم الافتتاح التي وصلت بالسيارة وتم
تقديمها للجميع قبل الذهاب
إلى المبنى الذي تعالجني
بالطبع وبالطبع طارنا
المعيار الملكي هو حقل جوردون الذي
صممه وأشرف على مركز التجارة وهنا
هو مع الملكة في حفل الافتتاح
جنبًا إلى جنب مع المهندس المعماري الرئيسي جون
هاريس  أليس هذا ما تراه
الآن ، فأنا أعرف مدينة ضخمة من
المباني الشاهقة وكان المركز التجاري هو
الذي قال إن كل شيء قد يبدو
واضحًا الآن لبناء مركز أعمال في
واحدة من أغنى الدول على هذا
الكوكب وستجذب
الشركات العالمية ولكن في السبعينيات من القرن الماضي ، كان هذا
شيئًا جديدًا إلى جانب جوردون في هذه
الصورة ، حيث تم الاستشهاد بـ Schaffer OSH
في محاكاة لتوني حاكم دبي
ورئيس وزراء
دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي تم تشكيلها حديثًا ، كانت فكرته هي
بناء ناطحة سحاب مركز التجارة  في
المقام الأول لعدة قرون كانت الصناعة الرئيسية في دبي
هي حصاد اللؤلؤ ولكن في
ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي انهارت صناعة اللؤلؤ
بسبب الكساد الكبير
واختراع اللؤلؤ الصناعي ، ولكن بعد
بضعة عقود كان لدى دبي
مورد آخر غير مستغل إلى حد كبير ينتظر
التدفق إلى السوق في  عام 1966 لشراء
النفط الموجود وتشير التقديرات إلى أن
عدد السكان نما بمقدار 1000
على مدى الأربعين عامًا التالية بحلول عام 1991 ، حيث
شكل الذهب الأسود حوالي 50 ٪ من
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي لدبي مما أدى إلى ارتفاع  بيئة العمل للأعمال الجديدة ،
استخدم الشيعة هارشاد
عائدات نفط دبي لتطوير البنية التحتية للمدينة ،
بما في ذلك
بناء المركز التجاري ، أول ناطحة سحاب
في بلد ما ، ليس بالأمر السهل ، على
الرغم من أن الرمال في الصحراء
لم تكن مناسبة للإسمنت نحن  في الواقع ،
كان علينا استخدام الرمال من الشاطئ في
مكانه ، فقد استولت على
شيء غريب إلى حد ما يجب القيام به في الصحراء حيث
لم ير أحد مثل هذا المبنى الطويل
قبل انتشار الشائعات بسرعة ،
وكانت هناك أعمدة إنارة ليست بعيدة والتي
لم تكن كذلك  رأسيًا تمامًا وأعتقد
أن هذا ما بدأ الغرفة كانت في
الواقع مائلة ، وإذا لم يكن ذلك
كافيًا عندما وصلوا إلى الطابق العاشر
من مركز التجارة ، فقد قرر Chikara
أنه يريد أن يكون أطول ، لذلك طالب
بأرضيات إضافية ليتم وضعها في الأصل ، فقد تم
تصميمه  مع 33 ثم قاموا بزيادةها
إلى 39 اليوم ، يعد البرج 1.3 مليون قدم مربع
موطنًا لـ 500 حدث سنويًا
يجتذب 3 ملايين شخص من 160
دولة إذا سألتني في عام 1979
أصبحت دبي مركزًا سياحيًا كنت
سأقول ما الذي تدخنه ، أعتقد
أن عنصر الشك حول سبب
إنفاق الكثير من الأموال على هذا
البرج الضخم والمباني المحيطة
بسرعة تبخرت لأن
المكانة التي تمكنا من استغلالها كانت
لتأسيسها وتأسيسها ، تمتلك دبي
عنوان الأعمال الأول في
الشرق الأوسط